russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met the
ukrainian people
while he may make gains on the
battlefield he'll pay a continuing high
price over the long run
president biden vowing vladimir putin
will pay a price for his invasion of
ukraine but russia's brutality showing
no signs of slowing down
[Applause]
putin reigning bombs down on the
country's second largest city of kharkiv
striking a police headquarters and
targeting residential areas ukraine says
more than 2 000 civilians have been
killed so far in the war
the capital of kiev also being targeted
with buildings there being reduced to
rubble the pentagon says russian forces
are trying to advance across the country
but are being met with fierce ukrainian
resistance
trey yanks is in keeve with the latest
trey
good afternoon tension remains high in
kiev people here understand that the war
is now at their doorstep sometimes the
difference between life and death in the
ukrainian capital is up to timing and
chance
vanya was born this morning at 10 a.m as
airaid sirens sounded across keeve now
he rests next to his mother in the
basement of a maternity hospital for
families who are staying in the
ukrainian capital the days ahead are
expected to be bloody and violent
they're bracing for the worst a world
who who can help us help us
save us as new lives are brought into
this world the war is taking others out
across town five people were killed
overnight in russian missile strikes
bringing the total since the invasion
began to more than 2 000 according to
state emergency services
overnight a russian missile slammed into
this building next to a television tower
in the capital of kiev the air campaign
against this city is getting heavier as
ground forces get closer with the threat
from russia present inside the city
limits the ukrainian territorial defense
remains on alert while the bulk of
russian forces are staged outside of the
city every car that passes must be
considered suspect
they're coming from different sides a
lot of people came here before the war
started they rented places to live and
were getting prepared
in recent days kiev has seen some street
battles it's significant as troops here
do anything they can to block the
offensive that's taking place they're
moving pianos sand and concrete barriers
into the road they want to slow down
those russian forces back to you
trey stay with us we've got some
questions for you and i'll start with
the first
you know as you talk about the street
battles and people even pulling out a
piano to stop the russians are the
ukrainians disappointed did they expect
more from the rest of the world that is
literally just watching this
they're expecting more from the world
right now they've made very clear
officials here in the capital of kiev
that they need two things they need more
sanctions on president putin of russia
to try and alter his behavior and they
need weapons in the form of anti-tank
missiles they want anti-aircraft
batteries and everything that can be
given to them in the coming days we know
according to reports some stinger
missiles arrived here in the ukrainian
capital today this will give them the
ability to shoot down helicopters and
small aircraft but moving forward the
things they will need most has to do
with air power they want to control the
air above them we know today a cruise
missile was intercepted over this city
fighter jets being shot down and these
air battles taking place so it's not
just the ground they have to worry about
but also the air
all right i'll go to you greg all right
first trey you are a badass
uh and you're doing amazing work and
thank you for that um we keep hearing
stuff about gains on the battlefield and
reports that putin is under pressure and
things are going badly for russia and
things are going great for or better for
ukraine how can we tell i mean you were
there you're showing some amazing
pictures so we know what we're seeing is
happening
what do we know about these other
stories how can we tell whether they are
true or not whether they are persuasion
as opposed to
actual facts what do you think
look i think the focus right now is
really on two cities despite the fact
that we've seen fighting erupt across
this country kharkiv the second largest
city there is significant evidence that
the russians are targeting civilian
areas and they continue their offensive
both by air and ground
the other thing to focus on is the
capital of kiev and this convoy that
according to satellite images is nearly
40 miles long artillery units tanks
russian soldiers and it has been stalled
for the past 48 hours and officials here
believe that has to do with logistics so
this will be really the focus in the
coming days whether or not these troops
continue their advance toward the
ukrainian capital and if they do the
real understanding here is they will try
to encircle the city so i think that's
going to be the thing that people focus
on in the coming days is this convoy
moving and if they're not moving why is
that and it could be for two major
reasons they're regrouping and preparing
to launch that assault on the city or
they could be having logistics problems
in the forms of food fuel and supplies
dana trey one of the things president
biden continues to say and almost at
almost every opportunity it's almost
more for a domestic audience i think is
that american soldiers will not have
boots on the ground in ukraine
but to be clear the ukrainians have
never asked for that they asked for what
you said beforehand that's a little bit
of a straw man that he's putting up
there we understand that american boots
on the ground will not be in ukraine
yeah right now the white house is being
very clear that there will be no
american troops fighting in ukraine the
ukrainians though are really looking for
weapons right now they aren't begging
the world to send troops here they are
asking for and pleading for
anti-aircraft batteries these anti-tank
missiles and other weapons that they can
use